نعود الى السياسه حيث دخلت الحرب
الاوكرانيه مرحله ساخنه جديده مع اعلانات
متواتره عن كاف عن بدء الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد الذي طال انتظاره ورغم ان رئيس
الاركان الاوكراني اعلن انه ليس لديه
معلومات حول ما يتم تداوله لكن اربعه
مسؤولين عسكريين اوكرانيين كشفوا لصحيفه
واشنطن بوست عن بدء الهجوم بالفعل موضحين
انه يتم في هذه الاثناء تكثيف الهجمات على
طول خط المواجهه جنوب شرق البلاد بهدف
تحرير مدينتي
لكن المراقبه الامريكيه لهذه التطورات لم
تاتي بانباء مشجعه لكياف اذ نقلت سي ان ان
عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر كبيره في هجومها
الاول
قائد مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
يفغيني بيجوجين قال ان المعارك على الجبهه
تؤكد ان اوكرانيا بدات هجومها المضاده
واوضح بريكوجين ان اوكرانيا كثفت هجماتها
على جبهات ومعربا عن امله في ان تتمكن
القوات الروسيه من التعامل مع هذا الهجوم
وصده
اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه عن توجيه
ضربه وقائيه بالمدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات بعد محاوله اختراق فاشله
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
حول العدو اختراق دفاعاتنا بقوات اللواء
الميكانيكي السابع والاربعين والذي يصل
تعداده الى 1500 فرد ومائه وخمسين عربه
مدرعه
تم اكتشاف العدو في الوقت المناسب من قبل
قوات الاستطلاع وتم توجيه الضربه الوقائيه
بالمدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه المضاده
للدبابات في جميع الاتجاهات الاربعه تم
ايقاف العدو وتراجع مع خسائر فادحه وقوات
العدو الاحتياطيه المدربه خصيصا لتنفيذ
هذا الاختراق لم تنجز مهمتها
وانضم الينا من القاهره احمد عليبه الباحث
في وحدات الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه اهلا بك
سيد احمد يعني يبدو ان الهجوم المضاد بدا
وسط
انكار اوكرانيا حتى الان ولكن مسؤولين
امريكيين يتحدثون عن خسائر يتكبدها الجانب
الاوكراني كيف تفسر هذا التمويه والانكار
من الجانب الاوكراني
وتوقيت
انطلاق هذه العمليه المضاده وارتباطها
بتفجير الصدر ربما
بالتاكيد ممكن نقول انه العمليه الهجوميه
او العمليات المضاده من الجانب الاوكراني
قد بدات بالفعل لانه اوكرانيا لم تعد في
موقع دفاع كما كانت عليه الامور فيها
السابقه لان تطور الجون تطور هجمات في
مناطق مختلفه بغض النظر عن المكاسب
والخسائر هذا على مستوى اتجاهات المعارك
المساله الاخرى انه صحيح هناك تقديرات
امريكيه انه بدا بالفعل او انه هناك خسائر
بالفعل في هذه العمليه اكدها الجانب
الروسي
بما اشار اليه وزير الدفاع بانه اللي هو
47 واللي هو 47 مهم في هذه المساله تحديدا
لانه هو اول واهم اللي هو يحظى بتسليح من
الناتوكا والقواعه العسكريه بهذا الشكل
المساله الاخرى انه هل اوكرانيا بدات
الهجوم المضاد بمعنى العمليات بهذا الشكل
او بشكل تقليدي متعرف عليه لا قد يكون
هناك يعني محاولات من اوكرانيا لفرض قواعد
جديده للاشتباك بمعنى انه ما جرى في منطقه
خرسون وبعد عمليه تفجير السد وما يجري في
منطقه بلغراد وما يجري حتى ايضا في منطقه
خركيف بعد عمليه تفجير خط الامونيا انا
اعتقد انه هناك اتجاه لانه الجانب
الاوكراني ياخذ
مبادره الخط الهجومي وليس الدفاعي مهما
كانت الخسائر التي يمكن ان يتحملها في هذه
المساله هل هناك ارتباط ربما هناك ارتباط
بالفعل لانه
الجانب الروسي في منطقه خرسون بالتاكيد او
في المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه هو في موقع
متازم الان فيما يتعلق بخط الدفاع الاول
تراجع من مسافه حوالي 15 كم من الضفه
الشرقيه للنهر الى اكثر من 60 كيلومتر
ومساله التراجع يعني حينما تبدا اوكرانيا
بهذا الشكل هذا معناه انه الجيش الروسي في
وضع ارتباك يعني
مدفعيته جزء كبير جدا منها مضاداته
يعني الياته جزء منها تحت المياه في هذه
المعركه الارضيه من خنادق والى اخره وهي
ايضا غامرتها المياه في هذه المرحله
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه الجانب الاوكراني
سوف يطور الهجمات في هذه المنطقه خلال
الفتره المقبله لكن في نفس الوقت هل
الجانب الاوكراني مستعد لان يقدم الكثير
من الخساره سوف يلجا بالاحرى الى العمليات
الخاصه
على سبيل المثال كما يحدث فيه بالجرود
لانه احنا بعد عمليه تفجير السدر بدانا
نشوف انه هناك متغيرات في هذا الاتجاه
ايقاع عدد كبير جدا من الخسائر اسرار
كبيره من الدرونز بتهاجم مناطق في منطقه
بتدعم الالويه اللي بتتحرك على الارض سواء
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من القاهره احمد عليبه
البحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه
في مركز الاهرام للدراسه السياسيه
طبعا لا ننسى ان هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي
يتم الحديث عنه بينما تظهر الصور الوارده
من الميدان غرق المباني والمنازل في خرسون
وغيرها من المناطق بعد تدمير سد نوفا
كخوفكا
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه المشاهد التي تابعناها لغرق
الكثير من الاراضي بالتاكيد سيكون لها
تداعياتها على سير المعارك خاصه مع
الشواهد على بدء الهجوم المضاد فالمياه
اغرقت الكثير من التحصينات الميدانيه
الروسيه طبعا نتحدث عن الخنادق والمخابئ
التي كانت مباشره مقابل هذا النهر والتي
صممت للحمايه من اي تحركات اوكرانيه عبر
النهر طبعا معهد الدراسات الحرب الامريكيه
قال ان الانفجار اثر بشكل اكبر على الطرف
الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا تحديدا من نهر نظرا
لانخفاض الضفه على هذا الجانب قياده
العمليات الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه قالت ان
القوات الروسيه نقلت افرادها ومعداتها
العسكريه الى مسافه تبعد خمسه عشر
كيلومترا من منطقه الفيضانات ما يضع
القوات الروسيه خارج مرمى نيران القوات
الاوكرانيه على الضفه الاخرى قال معهد
الدراسات حرب ان القوات الاوكرانيه على
الجانب الغربي من النهر اجبرت على اخلاقي
او اخلاقي مناطقها تحت النيران المدفعيه
من القوات الروسيه على الجانب الشرقي من
النهر ويرجح خبراء ان الجانبين لن يطور
المعارك الى حد كبير في انتظار انخفاض
مستوى المياه قبل اتخاذ خطواتهما
الميدانيه المقبله في الطرف الاوكراني
تبدو فكره عبور النهر خيارا غير مرجح نظرا
للصعوبه وايضا لتكلفه العمليه اضافه
لافتقار اوكرانيا للقدرات البرمائيه لكن
النقطه الايجابيه مشاهدينا بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني هي ان الفيضانات بدات بالفعل
تجرف التحصينات وحقول الالغام التي
اقامتها القوات الروسيه في تلك المنطقه
ومع ذلك لن يكون التاثير النهائي للفيضان
في ساحه المعركه واضحا لعده ايام او ربما
[موسيقى]
وفيما يتعلق بتاثيرات تدمير سد نوفا
والهجوم على خط تصدير الامونيا الروسي
قالت ان خسائر المحاصيل في مقاطعه خرسون
بلغت اكثر من 100 الف طن بينما اكد
الكرامل ان تفجير خط انابيب سيعقد الموقف
فيما يتعلق بتمديد صفقه الحبوب مع كياف
بعد ايام من استهداف سد كخوفكا والاضرار
الناتجه عنه تتصاعد اعمده دخان تنذر
بماسات جديده استهداف جزء من اطول خط
انابيب للامونيا في العالم بطول
2470 كيلومترا في منطقه خاركيف الاوكرانيه
هذا الخط يمد العالم بالامونيا الضروريه
للزراعه لكنه بمثابه قنبله موقوته تزداد
المخاوف من التسبب في اضرار جسيمه للناس
والبيئه بسبب استهدافه الامونيا يمكن ان
تؤدي الى فشل الجهاز التنفسي في حال
استنشاقها اما في حاله التعرض لها كمركب
سائل فستؤدي الى تاكل الاعضاء التي تتعرض
لها وعند الانفجار في خط الانابيب يجب
اتخاذ خطوات فوريه ومحدده لضمان سلامه
الافراد وتقليل التاثير البيئي واصلاح
الضرر
اخلاء المنطقه المجاوره ثم الاستجابه
للمواد الخطره وهذا يحتاج الى فرق المواد
الخطره المتخصصه للتعامل مع الموقف احتواء
التسرب ومنع انتشار الامونيا قد يشمل ذلك
قطع الامداد اذا كان ذلك امنا واستخدام
التقنيات وموده محدده للحد من انتشار
الغاز قد تحتاج السلطات الى توسيع منطقه
الاخلاء حسب شده التسرب على المتخصصين
تقييم الاثار البيئيه الفوريه والمحتمله
على المدى الطويل للانفجار والتسرب يمكن
ان يساعد ذلك في توجيه عمليه التنظيف
والتدابير الوقائيه المستقبليه على
المتخصصين تنظيف المنطقه المصابه وتطهير
اي معدات او هياكل او ارض متاثره
بالامونيا
تت
ابعون اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
ودعم في مجمع الصناعات العسكريه جنوب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احتفل دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والعراق في مدينه الخبر السعوديه
باعلان بدء مشروع ربط الكهربائي الخليجي
بين دول مجلس التعاون والعراق يذكر ان
التشغيل المشروع سيكون مع نهايه العامل
المقبل وسيزود المشروع جنوب العراق
بالطاقه الكهربائيه حيث سيكون باكوره
التعاون والتبادل التجاري بين دول مجلس
التعاون والعراق بحسب هيئه الربط
الكهربائي الخليجي طبعا يتكون المشروع من
ثلاثه مراحل حيث تبدا المرحله الاولى
بتجهيز محافظه البصره بجنوب العراق
بجهد خمسمائه ميجا وات يمكن رفعها بحسب
الحاجه فيما بعد الى 1000 ميجا وات في
مراحل متقدمه
وخلال الحفل اكد وزير الطاقه السعوديه عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان الربطه الكهربائي بين
دول الخليج والعراق يحقق فوائد اقتصاديه
ملموسه
في هذا كله هو عمل يعزز قدره العراق على
تلبيه تحتاجات
الاقتصاد العراقي الشقيق من الكهرباء في
السنوات القادمه كما سيعزز امن واستقرار
الشبكات الكهربائيه المترابطه واود هنا ان
نعبر عن تقديري
وتقديم العمل لتقديم العمل في المشروع
كهرباء ربط الكهربائي السعودي في العراق
المباشر الذي يشرف عليه فريق عمل مشترك من
المملكه ومن العراق
اكد وزير الكهرباء العراقي زياد فاضل على
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمشروع الربط
الكهربائي
وضع الحجر الاساسي لمشروع الربط الذي
يتضمن تنفيذ خط بدائرتين من محطه الزور
الثانويه مرورا مرورا بمحطه الوفره الى
محطه الفاو وبطول كلي 322 كيلومتر وان
مقدار الطاقه المتوقعه المتوقعه استيرادها
من خلال هذه الخط كمرحله الاولى سيبلغ 500
ميجا [__] لتغذيه محافظه البصره
وانضم الينا من بغداد احمد موسى المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره الكهرباء العراقيه اهلا
بك سيد احمد يعني اتفاق الربط هذا بين
مجلس التعاون الخليجي وايضا العراق طال
انتظاره الى اي مدى سيحل مشكله الكهرباء
التي يعاني منها العراق منذ سنوات
خطوه استراتيجيه مهمه جدا للشبكه
الكهربائيه يعزز لان يكون العراق بلدا
ممررا وحافظا الطاقه
طيب سيد احمد يعني المرحله الثانيه
والثالثه اي مدن ستستفيد منها وباي قطاعات
بما انه المرحله الاولى ستستفيد منها
البصره تحديدا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان المرحله الاولى
التي هي عباره عن 500 ميجا وات ستكون
لمحافظه البصره من خلال ربط سبلت سبلت
يعني منتهي تستفيد منه محافظه البصره ب500
وبالتالي جزء من المتعلقات التي كانت هي
من جمله التزامات وزاره الكهرباء العراقيه
وانجزت ربما باكثر من 80% كان يستلزم من
شعر الخطوط الناقله كان يستلزم انشاء محطه
الفاو التحويليه ذات الجهد 400 كيفي
وبالتالي اكتملت واليوم العراق قبل ما
حفله تنفيذ يعني حفل التنفيذ هذا الربط
كان قد ناقش مع هيئه الربط الخليجي ما يلي
اولا ناقش جمله العقود الموقعه من الجانب
الخليجي لانجاز خط هذا الخط يعتبر لبنه
اخيرا لربط محطه الوفره داخل الكويت في
محطه الفاو داخل البصره ومن ثم ناقش تهيئه
المرحله الثانيه والثالثه شنو يستلزم
الثانيه الثانيه يستلزم تطوير الربط هذا
ليشمل محافظات غير البصره اللي تشترك بعده
محافظات داخل العراق والمرحله الثالثه
يؤسس لان يكون العراق بلدا ممررا للطاقه
بحكم ان الطاقه المنتجه والمورده ستكون من
دول الخليج سيتمرر الى دول اوروبا ومن ثم
الى تركيا وحتى دول شرق اسيا يكون بحكمها
العراق بلدا ممررا وحافظا لامن الطاقه
ومحورا ستراتيجيا لتبادل منفعه الطاقه
وبالتالي كل المحافظات العراقيه ستستفيد
من هذا الربط
يعني هذا بالمرحله الثانيه نعم بالمرحله
الثانيه نبحث الان ان تستفيد منه عموم
المحافظات ست راويه اليوم احنا نتكلم
بالعراق هنالك فجوه ما بين العرض والطلب
هنالك اليوم زياده بالطلب على الاستهلاك
تقابلها نقصان نوعا ما بحجم الانتاج
المتاح وبالتالي هذا يقتضي العمل على
تنويع مصادر الطاقه اللي واحده منها
مشاريع الربط الكهربائيه مره ذهبنا باتجاه
الربط الخليجي ومره سنذهب باتجاه الربط مع
السعوديه اللي هو الربط السعودي وذهبنا
باتجاه تركيا وايضا لدينا ربط باتجاه
المملكه الاردنيه نرى ان مشاريع الربط
الكهربائي وخصوصا مع الربط الخليجي مع دول
الخليج السبعه سيحقق مكاسب استراتيجيه
وكبيره اهمها العوده الى الحضن العربي ومن
ثم الربط اقليميه مع دول الجوار ومن ثم
الفائده الفنيه المرجوه للشبكه الكهربائيه
واللي ستطلع بزياده ساعات تجهيز الكهرباء
بالعراق طبعا شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من بغداد السيد احمد موسى
المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الكهرباء
العراقيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
الامير فيصل من فرحان اكد كذلك على التزام
جميع المشاركين في الاجتماع الوزاري
للتحالف الدولي في الحد من مصادر تمويل
الارهاب ووسائل نشره خلال اجتماعتنا اليوم
ناقشنا سبل اعاده استقرار في الاراضي
المحرره للتنظيم داعش في سوريا والعراق
باعتبارها من ضمن قائمات لدى التحالف
واكدنا على اهميه استمرار الجهود في هذا
الاطار كما اكد المشاركون على الالتزامهم
واستمرارهم في الحد من مصادر التمويل
الارهاب ووسائل نشره والترويج كما تجد
الاشاره هنا اذا ترسل المملكه لمجموعه
مكافحه التمويل داعش وجهودها الكبيره في
اطار تنسيق عمل كافه الدول في التحالف
للتصدي لتمويل هذا التنظيم كما بحثنا
الاجراءات التي يمكن اتباعها لمجابهه
الارهاب والميليشيات المسلحه في غرب
افريقيا ودول الساحل ووسط وجنوب افريقيا
وكان وزراء خارج الدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اكدوا
في بيان مشترك على اهميه جهود تخفيض
التصعيد في المنطقه اشدد الجانبان على
اهميه دعم الحقوق والحريات الملاحيه وجهود
التصدي لاي تهديد ضد امن السفن كما شدد
الوزراء على اهميه مواجهه الارهاب والتطرف
العنيف في جميع انحاء العالم وعبر البيان
عن الالتزام بالتوصل الى سلام عادل ودائم
وشامل في الشرق الاوسط وفقا لحل الدولتين
ورفض اي اجراءات احاديه وخاصه في القدس
كما شدد على ضروره التزام ايران بالتعاون
الكامل مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه ورحب
باستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وايران وبشان السودان اشد البيان
بجهود الرياض واشنطن عبر منبر جده للوصول
الى اتفاقا لوقفه اطلاق النار
خلال اجتماع بين وزراء الخارجيه وزير
الخارجيه تحديدا الامريكيه ورئيس مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني رشاد الاعلامي في
الرياض عبر عن قلقه من ممارسات الحوثيين
التي تحول بين اليمنيين والموارد فيما
ابلغ بلنكن رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي
اليمني ان اطراف الصراع في اليمن عليهم
التوصل لاتفاق جديد اكثر شمولا لانهاء
الحرب ونقش وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اثناء
اجتماعه حل الصراع في اليمن في اقرب وقت
ممكن وتخفيف من الازمات الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
شهد محيط مجمع الصناعات العسكريه في جنوب
الخرطوم اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بعد اعلان الاخيره
سيطرتها عليه وقال شهود عيان انهم سمعوا
اصوات اطلاق نار واشتباكاته كما شاهدوا
حريقا في المنطقه المحيطه بمجمع اليرموك
تدعيه الحرب ازدادت اعداد الوفيات بين
الاطفال في دور الايتام في السودان بسبب
سوء التغذيه والجفاف ما دفع اليونيسف
لاجلاء حوالي 300 منهم
الوضع صعب جدا يا جماعه الخطر على كل
الناس ترجمه لصرخاتي يتيم ووضع صعب في دار
الايتام هنا باختصار رضاع يناشدون على
طريقتهم
امبارح هم لا يدركون لكن ثمه تداعيات حرب
حاضره فوق رؤوسهم وفي امعائهم ايضا
اطفال توفوا جوعا في الخرطوم رصه الجثث
تباعا خلال شهرين الماضيين سبعون يتيما
رضيعا واطفال اكبر سنا لم يقاوموا تداعيات
الجوع اكثر
ايتام في دور اخرى محظوظون قوافل للامم
المتحده جاءت لاجلائهم شيء من السكينه
للاطفال وللعاملون ايضا
نحن سعداء حقا اننا استطعنا تنفيذ هذا
الاجلاء ويمكننا كمنظمه محايده في عمليات
اخرى استطعنا الحصول على جميع الضمانات
الامنيه
اجلاء تحقق بنجاح لكن الاطفال لم تتاثر
اجسادهم فقط بل يعانون من امراض عقليه
ونفسيه جراء الحرب
كان من المحزن حقا ان نرى كل هؤلاء
الاطفال يعاني بعضهم من حاله صحيه عقليه
وحالات صحيه اخرى
تسارعت عمليات الانقاذ بعد ارتفاع معدلات
الوفيات حالتين الى اربع يوميا فيما توفي
50 طفلا وعشرون رضيعا منهم 13 توفوا دفعه
واحده في السادس والعشرين من مايو الماضي
اطفال وان قاوموا يواجهون الان مستشفيات
خاويه لا ترعى غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والوضع في
نيويورك التي يبدو انها تعافت من اثار
دخان حرائق الغابه في كندا وفي اخر
الاجراءات الاحترازيه كانت اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه علقت الرحلات الجويه من شمال
شرق ولايه اوهايو الى مطار
لاجوارديا في نيويورك مؤقتا
وكان رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عرض على رئيس
الوزراء الكندي جاستنتو المساعده لاخماد
الحرائق في كندا وقالت الرئاسه الامريكيه
في بيان ان بايدن امر بتوفير كل القدرات
الفيدراليه المخصصه لمكافحه الحرائق التي
يمكن ان تساعد بسرعه في اخماتها
دخان حرائق كندا يخنق جيرانها الولايات
المتحده اول المتضررين وقد لا تكون اخرهم
السلطات الكنديه اعلنت محاولتها اخماد نحو
423 حريقا نشطا
246 منها خارجه عن السيطره تسببت الحرائق
بالقضاء على حوالي ثلاثه ملايين وثمانمائه
فيما تحولت مقاطعه
للحرائق حيث ينشط فيها 160 حريقا الى جانب
عشرات الحرائق الاخرى في البرتا وكولومبيا
البريطانيه وانتاريو دخان حرائق الغابات
القادمه من كندا سيؤثر على اكثر من 55
مليون شخص في مناطق الشمال الشرقي ووسط
الولايات المتحده ابرزها نيويورك وبوسطن
وواشنطن نيويورك المعروفه عاده بسمائها
الصافيه سجلت اسوا مؤشر لجوده الهواء
عالميا وفق موقع اي كيو ار السويسري
المختص في مراقبه حاله الهواء
مخاوفه بانتقال الحرائق الى غابات
الولايات المتحده المتاخمه على بعد اكثر
من
5800 كيلو متر من كندا حيث تقع النرويج
يتوقع ان تدفع الرياح بدخان الحرائق الى
هناك وفق مسؤولين نرويجيين حيث سجلت
جزيئات متطايره من الدخان جنوبيا النرويج
بينما تحرك الدخان فوق جرين لاند وايسلندا
منذ الاول من يونيو الحكومه الكنديه تتوقع
استمرار نشاط الحرائق بصوره اعلى من
المعتاد وصدبابيه توقيت ومكان توقف السحب
الدخانيه وعوده الهواء لطبيعته لارتباطها
باتجاه الرياح وسرعتها
ويضم الينا من نيويورك الصحفي طارق
الدمشقي اهلا بك سيد طارق يعني ما الذي
يقال الان في نيويورك تحديدا عن
الحاله اللي هي بعد انقشاع السماء وهي
الان اكثر صفاء يعني هيئه الارصاد الا
تتخوف من ربما ان يكون هذا الانقشاع مؤقتا
في ظل الاستمرار
الحرائق في كندا ونشاهد هذه الصور
المباشره من مدينه نيويورك وانت تتحدث
معنا
صحيح تحيه لك حقا كافي حاكمه ولايه
نيويورك صرحت اليوم قالت على السكان
الولايه عموما والمناطق المتاخمه لها ان
لا يشعر يعني لا يصعد كثيرا بالحال الان
بعد يعني
انتشاع نوعا ما العاصفه الدخانيه لان
الحرائق ما زالت مستعره في الشرق الكندي
وحركه الرياح الان هي السبب بانقشاع هذه
الغيبات الدخانيه
وقد وقالت انهم ربما غدا سوف يتحسن الجو
ربما بعد غد سوف يبدا سوءا عن البارحه على
الجميع ان يكونوا على استعداد تام يعني من
الناحيه الصحيه وان يتبضعوا ان يكونوا
جاهزين
في اماكن المغلقه والمكيفه البعيده عن
الدخان احتسابا من اي ازمات قد تصيب الناس
الذين يعانون من الربو امراض الجهاز
التنفسي وايضا الازمات القلبيه هذا بشكل
عام ما حدث حتى الان من تصريحات رسميه عن
المسؤولين في ولايه نيويورك حاكم ولايه
نيوجيرسي المتاخمه
والمسؤولين الصحيين في الولايه قالوا على
يعني على الجميع ان يتخذوا الحيطه ايضا
هناك حرائق مشتعله في بعض الغابات في
ولايه نيوجيرسي السلطات تقوم باخمادها
وايضا هناك عده مدارس تم صرف الطلاب اليوم
ومدن كبيره مثل مدينه نورك ومدينه
اليزابيث
بالاضافه الى مدينه ينكر ينكر الموجوده في
ولايه نيويورك ثالث اكبر مدينه قامت
باغلاق المدارس بشكل تام اليوم وربما غدا
سوف يغلقوها ايضا احترازا من اي تصاعد او
لك عاصفه دخانيه مماثله قد تؤدي صحيه
للاطفال
بشكل عام نعم السيد طارق يعني تحدثت عن
حرائق مشتعله في ولايه نيوجيرسي يعني هل
هنالك مخاوف من انتقال هذه الحرائق الى
مدن اخرى
ليس هناك تصريحات جدا يعني رسميه حول ذلك
حتى الان ولكن يعني الحقائق التي اشتعلت
في ولايه نيوجيرسي بدات منذ ثلاثه ايام
وجلست الاطفاء تحاول اخمادها منذ فتره
ولكن ليست يعني بحجم السوء الذي تسببته
حرائق الشرق كندا حتى الان يعني السيطره
تامه على هذه الحرائق وهذا يعتبر موسم
الحرائق في يعني ولايه في الشرق الشرق
الشمال الامريكي
ولكنها كما قلت لك هي تحت السيطره تم
توزيع حتى الان ما يقارب مليون ومئه الف
قناعمه من نوع
في جميع المراكز الحيويه مثل محطات
الباصات والقطارات وايضا المطارات عوده
العوده طفيفه للحركه الجويه الى سابق
عهدها كانت قد حدثت منذ الصباح الباكر في
مطار الاكوانديا ثاني اكبر مطار في ولايه
نيويورك اما المطارات الاخرى الحركه نوعا
ما عاديه ولكن هناك تخوف من الناس لا
يريدون ان يخاطروا يعني
الجنود العام في الحركه الجويه والحركه
المروريه الناتجه عن صدمه ومفاجاه السكان
في هذه المنطقه لمثل هذه الظاهره الطبيعيه
التي اصابتهم فجاه التي لم يشهدوا مثلها
عبر تاريخه في امريكا حتى الان شكرا جزيلا
لك الصحه في طارق الدمشقي من نيويورك على
كل هذه المعلومات شكرا
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون امريكيون لصحيفه ووسط جونل
النصين وكوبا تواصلتا الى اتفاق سريا
لانشاء منشاه التجسس مواجهه ضد الولايات
المتحده وكشف المسؤولون عن ان الصين تخطط
لاعتراض الاتصالات الالكترونيه وايضا
لمراقبه
حركه السفن الامريكيه عبر المنشاه واضافوا
ان الصين وافقت على دفع مليارات الدولارات
لكوبا مقابل انشاء القاعده لكن البيت
الابيض خرج بتصريح قال فيه ان تقرير ووكسي
حول المنشاه الصينيه غير دقيق
في المقابل كشفت صحيفه فاين شيل تايمز عن
تعاون الولايات المتحده مع تايوان والدول
الحليفه المجاوره تحسبا لاي تحركات عسكريه
صينيه الصحيفه قالت ان الولايات المتحده
ستسلم تايوان اربع طائرات مسيره من طراز
ام كيو 9 بابتداء من عام 2025 وسيتم نشر
المسيرات في تايوان لاستطلاع الاوضاع في
المناطق المحيطه بالجزيره من اليابان
شمالا والى الفلبين جنوبا مسؤول عسكري
مشارك في التخطيط قال لفيننشل تايمز انه
سيتم تدريب القوات التايوانيه على استخدام
هذه المسيرات الى جانب نظرائهم الامريكيين
واليابانيين وفق الصحيفه من المقرر ان يتم
تشارك البيانات بين الولايات المتحده
وتايوان واليابان بشكل فوري ومباشر لتعزيز
التنسيق في حاله وقوع هجوم صيني على
تايوان بعد الحصول على صوره كامله لتحركات
بحريه
للجيش الصيني ومراقبه السفن الحربيه
والغواصات الصينيه طبعا حول هذه الجزيره
وبينما امتنعت وزاره الدفاع ان كان
الامريكيه او حتى اليابانيه ومكتب رئاسه
تايوانيه عن التعليق توقع مسؤول عسكري ان
تعتبر الصين الخطوه الامريكيه بمثابه تصعد
كبير
[موسيقى]
روسيا تنقل 300 طفل من بيلوجرود التي
تتعرض للقصف الى القرن التي تنتظر دورها
في القصف تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
تصريح اليوم لم نكن نملك خيارا سوى تعيين
حراس قضائيين لشركه بي يو كيو التصريح
صادر عن بنك
ان الشركه المعنيه فهي التي تصدر عنها
صحيفه
الصادره الاحد
يضيف البنك انه لم يستطع التوصل الى حل
حول ديونه لدى المجموعه والبالغه مليار
جنيه استرليني هذا اذا عملاقم صحفي اخر
يدفع ثمن مزيج من سوء الاداره وزمن يتغير
بسرعه الصاروخ ويتغير معه مزاج القارئ
فيديو اليوم من روسيا قرابه 300 طفل نقلوا
من منطقه بيلوجرود الى شبه جزيره القرم
بعد ان تعرضت بلداتهم لقصف اوكراني شبه
يوميا يعرف الاطفال الوضع جيدا في مناطقهم
ويحكون عن اصوات الرصاصي والصواريخ
المتكرره ويقولون ان الوضع هادئ في
مناطقهم الجديده لكن ما لا يعرفونه ان هذا
الوضع ربما لا يطول فاوكرانيا بدات هجومها
المضاده والهدف الكبير هو استعاده القرم
بالكامل
اما صوره اليوم فهي من الفلبين في اليوم
العالمي للمحيطات ينهمك العمال الحكوميون
والمتطوعون لتنظيف شاطئ العاصمه مانيلا
الجهد ده مشكور بالتاكيد لكن السؤال كيف
يمكن ان يصل اي شاطئ الى هذه الدرجه وربما
السؤال الدق الازال يصح ان يطلق على شيء
كهذا شاطئ
ساعتنا الاخباريه اشكركم مشاهدينا ننتقل
الان الى زميل صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه
مساء الخير صهيب مساء الخير راويه صحيح
بعد قليل الاخبار الساعه جولتنا اليوميه
السريعه الشامله المتنوعه لابرز اخبار
اليوم في الصداره سر توقيت تزامن الهجوم
المضاده الاوكرانيين مع تفجير سد كخوفكان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات